it was definitely the darkest moment it
was it was when i questioned everything
opening up to people tv about a nasty
fall that left his arm
shattered two years ago michael explains
how the incident led him to his lowest
point
waiting for the ambulance to come by on
the floor i just said well what have i
done
and then and if i can't put a i can't
put i can't put a shiny face on this i
can't
there's no there's no bright side to
this there's no upside this is just all
regret and pain the injury also came
just months after michael had to undergo
spinal
cord surgery to remove a non-cancerous
tumor which left him having to learn to
walk again
i just craved his freedom to just move
on my own and of course when i did
i fell down and broke my arm i knew i'd
be careless i knew i'd been i knew it
wasn't
just an accident that happened i know i
was pushing it
i was walking faster than i should have
and i was not paying attention michael
also opens up about his parkinson's
symptoms and how they've moved beyond
tremors and speech difficulties my
structural memory is gone and i always
had a real proficiency for lines and
and memorization of lines and i had some
extreme situations the last couple of
jobs i did were
actually really worried heavy parts that
i think
if i thought about it i would have
thought and maybe a little
lighter on the dialogue but but
i struggled doing both of them but
despite his health challenges
michael maintains a positive outlook i
love life
it's like i had a couple things i have
to deal with but i have things that i've
been blessed
with that are just incredible